[Music]
hey guys we're super excited today we
have Paul Scheer and Rob Huebel from
everything from human giant to
Children's Hospital to crash-test to out
these guys do a million things all the
time he's on believe the league my god
transparent transparent and today we're
here we're here and we're gonna be
playing gauntlets I'm excited about
gauntlet because gauntlet was the game
that kind of sucked ass but it was also
awesome as a kid like just kind of run
around and they awkwardly now this front
screen it already looks a million times
better to me monetize better and to make
things a little worse we're playing this
game right here
bean boozled and the deal is if you've
seen us do this before every time one of
us dies we have to spin the little wheel
up jelly bean wheel of death and it's
either gonna be a delicious jelly bean
or one that tastes like garbage so yeah
you know you we can't have guests here
without treating the poorly so there you
go has anyone gotten sick from the jelly
beans actually we did this with a cast
of teachers that show teachers one of
the girls I had like immediately jumped
up and spit out the rotten milk one so
I'll make a rule that you can't spit it
out all right that's a rule out of my
personal life
nope it's a rule that I have in my
twitch life I live that's a life rule
I hate bean boozled somebody already
said I love it hey shady fridge what's
going on alright in dis retro gauntlet I
loved it but it was not the highest of
graphic ability no I'm not gonna take my
shirt off Internet and I will say like
my sister and I we always play cuz you
couldn't keep moving so you just sit in
the corner just to annoy me
you can't yeah all right so uh most
important thing yeah choose your
character here also we've unlocked the
necromancer I don't know if you guys are
into necromancy oh of course I think I
gotta go old school there the elf is my
classic character that I used to play
okay I'm going I'm like Valkyrie I like
a strong woman
you know I cuz I kind of feel like a
strong woman she looks like she has some
skin disorders she yeah there's eczema
or something there but it acts it acts
there
I'm going warrior warrior alright let's
do it all right head axe we'll get into
it I need a bigger codpiece how do you
bend over to tie your shoes with that
skull in the way I think it would the
top of the skull if you like would dig
into you feel it yeah exactly that would
be alright alright so it's a little bit
like look at yes
let's see I think square oh here we go
are we supposed to work together yeah I
think I I think we're all pals ooh more
AK more a little a little arrogant more
act like I'm facing the wrong way
yeah you're so passive-aggressive you're
not even giving him big respect he just
more act deserves more AK is looking at
my butt crack guys we have to find the
three lost shards of turf thing I am
already lost in this game it is like
like one of those terrible movies of God
to be pissed and already like what's
happening just let me shoot arrows these
guys Oh
guys seriously we should make the
FaceCam smaller people really want to
get some of the amazing graphic theater
and see what's happening maybe we should
just make the FaceCam the whole video
and we should just describe and
illustrate I feel like running into a
giant flaming mouth it's always a good
start to a game and from here we go in
my personal life take our tombs of there
isn't anyone who let's do it I would
love to all right we keep saying we're
ready and again starting do it find the
lost shirts sit somebody there you go
keep it classy twitch alright
that's right I'm trying to figure out
what someone's saying you guys are the
best comedians ever in the whole world
to California alright we'll take it well
there you go I love you what's this gold
that's um gold gold I think he's this is
like kind of like old school yeah but
it's not it's not as updated as I
thought yeah I get some like some laughs
like you know like some new gaining no
not at all you know if it ain't broke
don't fix it and if it is broke just
don't also fix it just let it be broke
that's what I say mostly cuz I'm
laziness
wait that's you by the Shrek doing the
voice where's donkey I get donkeys yeah
yeah donkeys I don't know why you carry
turkey dinner well done look at those
guys down there all right I got a nice
dance move like that move that's pretty
sweet
there's more where that came from yeah
how do you what it though I found a
secret room over here oh I think I found
a key he was holding us back
sorry sorry got a key wait Rob you're in
wait you're in Keanu yeah how did it go
what did you do in Keanu I'm the
annoying neighbor I'm I'm Keegan's
annoying neighbor that hooks up with his
wife that's awesome
and I'm not in I'm like I'm about the
only white guy in the movie they needed
one white guy and so they called me out
you look with token white guy
yeah well I'm having a will go ahead a
shoot I think it's a square square I'm
hitting square nothing my guy what about
if you hit oh wait
well he's too I hit it twice bit twice
oh there you go wait oh that just now
it's oh I see oh wow okay now I got it
oh there you go perfect I think we need
to find some kind of a key are you gonna
key all right let's go this way then
we're walking to that big door all right
here we go my questions like what are
these guys doing when they're not
attacking us they're just hanging or
hanging out of each other look you know
a life in a dungeon oh I got killed
right oh dude I just learned you got it
I think you have to do the back boozled
thing all right Abu Ben bubi try it yeah
all right bean boozled all right spin
the thing cheers to it bean boozled all
right here we go
that's right what did we do there I'm
not quick this bean boozled lime or lawn
clippings I think it's one of those all
right lawn clippings doesn't seem too
hard yeah I'm from LA is like this could
be a foam paper this could be a Food
Network show you know what I'm saying
like you play video games and eat
there's like lawn clippings really yeah
what about that bad what Geordi yeah
like what did you think it was gonna
taste like maybe lime is my morale
grass or does it taste like leaves
that's a big branch or bark there's more
grass no dirt it's a very nice place
lawn clippings is kind of a blanket term
for all those things I agree that's the
thing that's a Jelly Belly is now
started using their powers for evil you
know I feel like they got too excited
about the Harry Potter thing yeah
they're AG wait till the hair what was
the every part of that because they had
jelly beans in Harry Potter yeah that
all tastes like poop it's the fuckbag
great so thanks okay Rolla yeah you just
your legacy your somebody asked that we
ever played anything oh yeah are you
guys gamers um I would like to play
games no I I don't I don't play with my
people with events hearts yeah yeah
always we go with luxguy whenever right
when and whenever I play a PlayStation I
feel totally my I just get confused by
it
what do you mean like I just the
controllers different to me and I don't
know if I feel as comfortable by oh
interesting you're so you're on edge
right now I am this is oh oh wait how
does that I will say they need to do a
thing where all the things are the same
yeah his ex on one is like why I'm here
oh that was me sorry I don't like this
Archer power any by nature that's right
gauntlet man alright here we go got this
me what's up Rob's the only one using
his special that's true wait how do you
use your special oh there we go
Oh circle I don't even know home do now
I'm figuring this now he's just a nano
barrier I'm just a natural I just like
to dance I just want to get out to the
floor oh yeah we Rob you're not a gamer
what was the last video game II play I
mean I played Call of Duty on Xbox for a
while Jews dying it I did die again
maybe the thing again just alright just
go number two where can he go number two
my arrow was alone it's a dungeon I
think anywhere basically it's in it it's
in a giant good here I'll hold it you
spin it right that was even worse very
good this is the worst spinner ever well
every era blue blue toothpaste
toothpaste come on that's nothing I'm
really avoiding easy alright let's eat
so far delicious toothpaste toothpaste
yeah man I don't have to brush that so
oh I got a late
oh he's back I'm back not telling him
that's me
oh my shirt today says virginity rocks
because we're playing gauntlet and so
this is kind of Dungeons and Dragons II
that's what I did by the way all in high
school I spent every Friday and Saturday
night at Denny's playing do you ever
play the Marvel Dungeons & Dragons I
never did that's a good one no I know I
can't kill all these guys by my sake I'm
cleaning house oh yeah now you have to
play there we go here we go no I'll be
back and once your body and got tons of
your the idea how fine it is to kill so
what you got buttered popcorn or rotten
egg here we go oh that's gonna be gross
watch definitely rotten egg they've
taken all the fun oh wow
that is Oh ma'am sorry I just I'm like
convulsing over here that was really bad
I'm totally not happy I got killed
because uh Oh God
we might have to put up yeah we may have
we might have to not do this at the end
of the girls I just exploded some
dynamite right in my own face and she's
still alive it's the warrior man okay
how do we get back how do we get back
down some kind of key okay robot oh man
that was that was really disgusting oh I
gotta get I had rotten egg glue lafon
and it was very rotten ewwww where are
you guys there's no spirit we're both
I'm not able to revive both dead alright
some do I have to keep going by myself I
think so I'm gonna go kill these yeah
that's life all right
we believe in you though I think if you
kill more guys we'll be able to come
back carry this axe
oh don't oh god get away get away are
you impressed with our twitched gauntlet
skills yeah how are we doing everybody
you're good Paul alright wait that's
what better oh no are you bad when you
like to really have to run you can even
vomit rotten egg I don't know what that
means - no wait tell as we're just
sitting here tell people not crash test
crash test is a special that Rob and I
did we took our stand-up show that we
normally do and put it on a moving bus
over la literally on a moving bus and
and we bumped into crazy people on the
street like legitimately crazy people on
the street 1 o'clock in the morning in
front of Mann's Chinese Theater
oh yes baby's heart accrues sang we met
two Johnny Depp's which you know is
funny at the time now it's a little bit
more they were they both the same era
Johnny Depp was ones like Johnny Depp
and one was Captain John it yeah and
then we loved in the Johnny Depp the
very gay anything for free and he was
like yeah I get a lot of stuff for free
I could I got a free taco a baja fresh
one
that was it so we dress up like Johnny
Depp you can get a three it's won a free
taco and an establishment not as popular
as Taco Bell if you dress them at Johnny
Depp or just get a coupon oh we're back
yeah we're about you back get in there
keep killing people now I can come back
I think we have to earn our I got killed
oh no you're back guys think you can
come back maybe it's up to you pop all
right oh that's awesome yeah and like
Aziz is in their court read Natasha
Leggero yes Earl Sweatshirt if you like
on future the guys from Reno 9-1-1
yeah playing the reading the character
from read another one that was going on
Jack McBrayer all the gun all the hits
yeah you can see it I am really this is
really somebody on the boards tell me
how to use my super power I need this
super powers badly right now and what is
it just are you just witty like what is
your
well the archer is witty yeah I think
that he just felt like he does equip
yeah it's just like it
take these quips that's awesome that's
it sorry I can't vlog I see a fetus yeah
it's really hard to talk in you guys
originally started in respecto Montalban
right yeah you guys met at the uprights
that we met it today we met at UCB in
New York yeah we were both way back in
the day kind of the first wave of guys
to like start taking classes yeah back
when Amy Poehler was teaching classes
yeah it's like we took all took classes
with like Amy Poehler Matt Walsh and so
but it was all guys like me cheer and
like or jury and Rob Riggle and
and all those guys how cool is it now
that like you guys have really taken
over Hollywood I mean you guys are doing
you guys are in everything look we're
here now and yeah man hear me we've
taken over gaming yeah thank God that
was a tough one all right come on you ah
but that's gotta be kind of neat
actually looks really cool too I mean we
were all we always feel like we were
just in the right place at the right
time you know like cuz now you should be
is so big I probably be scared to get
involved now but like at the time you
know they were just the theater was just
getting going so yeah that we had to put
up shows like every night of the week
and I swear we were performing in New
York like yeah five nights a week that's
crazy yeah we just had we got a lot of
stage time and remember and the reversed
the first UCB theater people don't know
it was an old yeah and people would come
in and they would be sitting down there
and they and they expect the start like
an improv show and they would get subs
that you would realize in the first
couple years we were performing that
people were like leave mid-show wasn't
that the show wasn't good is it good
we're not taking off our clothes that's
how it McBrayer got involved actually
he's a frequent contributor that's what
is happening dude we want to get back it
hit oxy vegan hacks and come back in oh
you're back where am I there you are the
rep there you go dude you're to take
that take that gold on the ride one of
the weirdest shows we ever did was a
show called robot TV with television for
robots by robots and it was basically
just an exercise to piss off the
audience we were just walk around in
yellow and white jumpsuits and sing sing
or a guy played an electric guitar who's
the craziest show but it was a midnight
Friday show so no ever like those cool
people are hanging out in midnight at
Friday I mean Robby you say you know
it's like right place the right time but
there is you guys I mean absolutely work
so Harley yeah for sure I mean you know
we didn't make any money for you know
the first ten years you know ice
you know yeah everyone was poor for so
long yeah but yeah until your make back
for Subway yeah but to subway but to
your point
haha fresh all right all right P Jared
oh happy Jerry but to your point it is
really fun to look around now and see
how many people from way back banner are
still like kicking ass in capsule yeah I
remember seeing like you and wriggling
kungfu grip like that yeah yeah yeah
that weird transitional theatre theatre
though yes it's like 10 minutes it was
like even giant was so damn good that's
right thanks buddy awesome
is there anything like are there any
character I mean you guys I mean have
created probably hundreds of thousand
characters over the years are there any
like characters that you guys love that
you haven't been able to bring to TV or
movies or anything that you get I had my
idea for a sketch that I've never been
able to do and I loved it so much and
the idea was um you know how you have
like a genie like a genie in a lamp or
yeah but I wanted one that you get you
were so psyched you got it but it's
broken
yeah so it kind of works but it doesn't
work so they would give you weird rhymes
but never actually actually you didn't
know what it meant to just kind of put
it in the closet of like an order track
and I've never been able to do that
although I did do a meth genie there we
go meth GD I feel like we still have
notebooks filled with ideas for sketches
that we never got to and like eventually
we'll have to go and do another sketch
show did you guys ever do when you would
get down the Shoji but you go and then
write your favorite highlights from the
show because sometimes like you come
sometimes yeah then not really but you
know any women from improvising yeah
from improvising sometimes it didn't
always translate out three greediest
here oh that's what I that's how I'm
known it's awesome killing it
woo I don't know what any of this stuff
is you guys got a lot of things really
got one mystery yeah no here we go
catacombs
that's where [ __ ] gets real an exchange
of this Archer yeah hit hit Circle
Circle time and then they I think you
got a wizard blows by the way oh it's
worse than the archer all right
necromancer because why no all right so
uh whoa look at necromancer
oh yeah look at her body here's a good
idea as a serial killer with short-term
memory loss I don't know if that would
be a great catch as much as it would be
violence it would just be like just
think I've seen you watch your hands
were rubbing that crack pipe
perfect exactly yeah I know I'm not sure
if that would be right yeah exactly what
is that I did I do think I said I would
suck someone's dick up for wearing
something like that with the mesh yeah I
had to be painted all balloon which was
the worst part
anyway if you guys are just joining us
we've got Paul Scheer and Rob Huebel
here from everything from transparent
through the league to crash-test but you
can see on that hominid central.com or
cc.com also filthy preppy teens which is
on the full screen and full screen app
which if you don't know what that is
don't be alarmed it's brand new
well the necromancy just kind of just
runs into peoplewe necromancer I think
creates other things to fight oh oh you
have to stay away from death in this one
okay I got killed by Dow this blows
right now sorry the neck remit the
necromancer is like the flash whoa look
at that doing a lot of running away
Oh Oh necromancy got tagged wait can you
uh
I can't regenerate just yet wait you're
back
no stay away from death I can't kill
death okay the fact that you can't kill
death is ridiculous
I agree even yeah it's like these guys I
can't believe let's just be so boring in
here nobody even has any phones or
anything to like look at well that's how
they're ready to attack you they're
ready to come out you're just pissed
don't be a great video game it's just
people looking at their phones that's
the kids what's called life right I'm
looking on that to the chat here right
how goes gauntlet got I'm ejaculating
Tom the Python Jack you lating happening
that's a lot of times people watch me
play stuff they will primarily executive
that's a natural yeah when you see Paul
do people know I mean
the people from your chat room like
meetup ever in real life oh no I hope
that I hope that would be inevitable can
you come back x-naught yeah I guess I
think I just killed death whoo
you did really think I mean he desired
only only Benjamin but death will never
die just this love will never die that's
true you know what that's very true
where you come hey Rob somebody said
that I love your man is your best
character you've ever played oh really
that's a good that's a total Congrats
yeah like when you say to cut in line
yeah here we go you say cuddly got a
great show he's like what's a yesterday
show yeah
the absolute worst you haven't had a
jelly bean yet but you've died and the
last time read by nature says barbarians
skull belt is the head of a former body
wears a skull on his belt for post
mortem in the oh Jesus oh [ __ ] wait a
second death keeps getting this period
all over the car sucks in this all right
whatever good what do you got I got as I
look like to you
lime or lawn clippings all right
he had that I'll do it again Merlyn
again but I feel like Paul's had the two
easiest one what is that
toothpaste and you would peach or barf
get that peach man you mean that barf
bro all right well get it so let's see
it could be peach though yeah it could
be peach or barf peach or barf man I
think this is every your Hulk your whole
showbiz career is come down to this
moment
oh yeah you're right you're right peach
or each bar bar hope it's barf cuz I
love barf oh this is peach perfect you
you and if it was barf I was gonna be
like wow you took that very well what
are you guys feeling I don't know about
Gauntlet are we liking Gauntlet are we
like we can we can always switch so if
we hate this Barbara this guy says birth
tastes amazing what maybe that guy's
barf I think it kind of depends about
what you what you what you eat where
your barfing up so your father's day
Paul my mother's day was great
my wife treated me to a great Father's
Day oh my god awesome
we lost our kid and now I'm not
technically a father it was hey it's
weird I'm really bummed out about it but
you know you know I just want to know
see I didn't want to miss playing
gauntlet on you know you know just
getting out and when you're gonna go
find your kid right I'm trying to figure
it out like and we're you know how did
it happen how it was it just it was a
roller coaster accident obviously of
course you know they're like you know
use the seatbelts and I'm like yeah I
don't want to listen to those rules I
don't play I make my own rules
yeah you know I don't live by anybody oh
crap here we go Wow this Death Egg is
coming on it on every level here
I think so not dead again like stop
signs suggestion you know like I don't
need to there's a lot of rules in life I
don't live by Rob I don't swallow
sometimes lunch - Mike wouldn't spit it
right out yeah well you have - doesn't
matter you say Curtis Sarris and then
growl like you're annoyed why you up
just say Curtis Soros which one do you
read how it went by quick Oh Curtis
Soros and growl like what like you're
mad Curtis Oris yeah it's very gentle
somebody wants me to sing the Doritos
theme song classroom human giant no I
don't even remember it 100 was a Dorito
action then the old man says hey
everybody I'm in a big old bag of
Doritos I remember that we didn't have
the rights from Doritos to actually do
that like if you do a sketch like that
you have to like ask permission shot
really we got this sketch where we're
making up dumb jingles for different
candies and snacks in the grocery store
yeah and yeah we shot like a million of
them because we didn't know who we were
gonna get permission from oh wow I think
my necromancer just built a coffin and
put people in it hahaha that's like some
WWE yeah I love that I feel like I'm
I've been dead for about 10 minutes yeah
maybe yeah you did another jelly bean
yeah this is there's no way it's good
yeah you had you made extra oh he's
gotta get that bar on one still when are
we going to Puerto Rico Rob when you go
and we go
driving it now I got me I keep it I keep
my village
I've been to Puerto Rico I got I shot a
movie with jean-claude Van Damme in
Puerto Rico what yeah I got kicked in
the face by jean-claude Van Damme oh my
god wasn't something he was lucky list
he wasn't supposed to kick me in the
face he was supposed to go like by my
face but his shoelaces hit me in the
face at like jean-claude van damme speed
no holy [ __ ] yeah that's crazy okay wait
I got one called booger or pear
I feel like Jacqueline is not that tall
right are you taller than jean-claude
yeah yeah a lot of people are taller
than jean-claude Van Damme and develop
your head just [ __ ] you up his butt good
legs go out
that's his fatalities what did you get
Oh wasn't good look I got like grass or
do yeah it's like I was trying to get
booger no we should just try eating them
and trying to identify what they are oh
my god that's a better game I don't want
to know what how did this get made we
have coming up oh yeah and that's a
podcast where you guys watch terrible
movies yes and the podcast I have coming
up this week is simply irresistible with
Sarah Michelle Gellar and a magical crab
who moving the crab makes food it's kind
of like a stupid version of ratatouille
oh okay ratatouille way before
ratatouille came out its pre run it to
free ratatouille right it's a prequel
basically wait can you get back in here
I'm yeah how did this get made is great
what's the worst I mean I'm sure you
must get this what's the worst movie you
see it's tricky because like sometimes
the worst movie is not what you even
want to talk about like what can I write
funny like to me I think one of the
craziest movies that we've seen oh wow
is oh man there's a great there was a
great movie called oh okay
Otto Schwartz Nagar is Hercules in New
York it was his first movie ever did he
ever did he can barely speak English I
and
is running around as Hercules and he
gets like involved in the wrestling
world and he makes a friend who sells
pretzels by the dock okay and is
ridiculous
it does it all work out for him well of
course I mean he goes back home this way
come through the door this is Bo Oh like
paint pen he goes what he goes back to
Mount Olympus knowing that you know what
life on Earth isn't better it's better
to be a god than in there oh great wish
I could have told you right now yeah all
right out the gate if you have the
chance to be a god or a mortal man
choose God I feel like if you were a god
what would look what's the first thing
you would do I mean I feel like shoot
lightning bolts I don't know why I where
that came from but why not right yeah
what I mean just be like it'd be fun to
have some kind of a superpower if your
God give you time travel is that a god
feature I mean I know that like in the
Bible there's no time traveling it's not
like Superman at the end super burner
they fly back in the world goes back
right exactly we all get killed I think
we all got killed I think we let's just
try a new room you guys try a jelly this
guy sucks just try one and we'll try to
you guys want to go into the grave of
the torturer or the palace of com1 Oh
what do you have what do you think it is
hold on that visits grasshoppers I got
toothpaste toothpaste
this is not bad oh it's actually a nice
palette Cline there should be more
candies that are a toothpaste flavored
oh this is um some kind of fruity thing
this is good
dead fish all right with dead fish oh
thank god
what do you got I did a movie or
something forget Nic Cage never know cuz
he I don't think they'd be I don't think
he'd be psyched one time I went to what
time I went to an estate sale of Nicolas
Cage's
what oh yeah yeah I heard about that was
crazier yeah here and it was nuts and I
bought all these little I've like so
much weird Nic Cage [ __ ] at my house I
have a weird meditation mmm thing you
supposed to stare at for like 15 minutes
without blinking and then it leave like
it revolves or just selling off yeah
we went to Michael Jackson's estate sale
Wow yeah right before he right before
you die yeah you see the pictures of you
type in no not before he died it was
when he was being slow yeah it was
before he died oh yeah was before you
but yeah but but it was he put
everything for sale because he needed
money and then he took it all back and
he was not gonna sell it but so we went
for like one weekend and look at all
Michael Jackson stuff and it was all
like really creepy like yeah kid related
I have a Flickr page you can look at my
Flickr page like Paul Scheer and Michael
Jackson options oh my god that's insane
I'm ready oh yes I'm ready
that's Korean blues rough I got all the
best thing I got oh wait guys we just
broke that Michael Jackson died to the
forum spoiler alert here we go cuz I
feel like it's a good metaphor for like
my life just hacking and slashing
through haters I got it you know I had
much higher expectations for this game
yeah and I feel like it's not as it's
kind of it I would rather be playing the
old gauntlet I wish that was a feature
that you could have on this huh that's
true like you could just hit a button
and it would go to the old yeah well I
wish the perspective wasn't get out of
there wasn't an aerial view yeah exactly
I would rather be on the floor she goes
off my bald spot I think which I don't
enjoy yeah I can only see like my
deltoids yeah yeah oh look at this look
at this win enemy just go wow don't get
in the middle of that he's got like the
Ghostbusters I use that was terrible
what just happened to me you've got like
Ghostbusters stuff
what are you guys thinking the new
Ghostbusters coming out I am I'm excited
I mean II wrote it right can you get it
be difficult she's it used to be easier
for Makonnen in sure and I would say Oh
what was she
that's right back in the day oh my York
days uh yeah New York this like mm let's
say too nice man this guy do we kill
this guy is there anything like that
okay no no you can't kill this guy Oh or
you can kill you also
yeah I think he's doing more of an
effective job at that exactly yeah you
guys were on the show a bunch yeah that
was how I made my money totally how I
paid my rent in the early days of doing
Conan bits what had you guys remember
any bits you were in oh I remember that
I became the go-to Ronald McDonald which
sucked
because you'd have to get painted as
Ronald McDonald all the time I just had
a barf jelly bean oh oh it's definitely
Bob and yes I get painted they also I
then there's a guy who became a who's a
professional clown that's got Brad
Aldous so then he got the Ron McDonald
stuff oh he stole the gig for me yeah or
took it happily exactly and so then I
think we do his own makeup you know mmm
perfect so that's our show that's how
cheap we are and then you can do your
own makeup you you're out you may go
guys I'm trying to think of the other
eye I remember her being a dant a jazzy
walrus but good by far the grossest
thing I ever had to do on Conan was a
desk drive where Conan would drive
around New York City on his desk and and
we had to either lay in the Meatpacking
District now if you go to me pastor
packing district is like a cool hip area
we're like fashionable people hanging
out but back then it was just a dirty
disgusting place were like literally
there's still blood on the ground from
the hill and and then I remember laying
I was a Hari Krishna which is like
somebody was like in a toga essentially
laying naked on the street and smelling
the blood of pigs Oh Conan bet I've ever
had to do oh did he even make air
oh thank god I told my parents to watch
they're very upset yeah the worst is
when you have to do something terrible
and it doesn't even make air oh yeah I
suck
I remember being part of a I did I was a
part of a news network called the
breathing in news network it was news
anchors that only talked when they were
when they were breathing in today I
can't even do it but like so I did do
that like all day long like do the
sports report like amazing you did build
one strength though I built up a lot of
Leung Chang which is why you can hold
your breath now for what five or 6 min
five or six minute is amazing three dies
what about there's ghosts up can we kill
these ghosts no I'm not sure what that
goes to do just like the entourage
brothers I thought you might this game
is like on do yeah this game is yeah it
goes on forever and have no point and no
one likes it Hank pool network I'm gonna
give you a shout out life is made
can I get a shout out the Hank pool
network there you go exactly Trump
should be goes how do we get out of this
room I don't know this is it's this is
hell on earth we should just switch to a
different level
oh my first appearance like Conan was
what was that my he cut my hair this is
I just started actually said it's
terrible wait did he cut you here in the
audience Oh No okay cuz I once I turned
down a bit were like he's gonna shave
your head in the audience oh no he he
they just opened this Hair Studio oh I
got another puke jelly back this is so
debilitated I'm going in Alfie said with
no pelvis oh oh I got something terrible
oh oh what is that oh yeah it's bad
right wizard sucks but you can try them
this is a great way if your son I'm dead
fan D yet to give him that you want to
wean your kids off candy you just give
me so they're like oh I hate candy wait
so he cut you really err really
you can really scar your children but
I'll [ __ ] this guy really I don't like
this uh-huh
Wow I just killed I just killed myself
you literally like ran at death and
you're just like later I'm out something
wants me to say something and that I
like to say from NTSF ah oh man I have
to think of a shitty pun
TSS what is the NTSF SD SUV yeah NTSF SD
SUV which is a show that I did a few
years ago where was like 24 but funny
I played Trent Hauser I was a kind of
like a more douchebag David Caruso and
you can watch them all now on Hulu and
it's got a nice I will say like did like
the digital world has made things I can
tell you guys who've made so much have
such a great body of work now you can
see it all except for human giant just
can't why is that that's crazy I don't
know they've been taking down we had a
YouTube page what we put up and they've
been taking it down oh that's madness
yeah it's been the weirdest thing we
like getting these we've been fighting
for years to try to get it somewhere if
someone wants me if you want me to say
the thing from NTSF just give me a
scenario and I'll give you a pun I can't
to juvey try did someone die ever give
me a significant C yes when I get from
yeah I need to be able to come up with a
crappy fun for you here we go here we go
do you guys as being a master of improv
fellows do you guys and we do have belts
in that like so we have to wear those
our master improv yeah exactly which is
weird
yeah yeah it's very it's you won't go on
without your belt yeah it's like a weird
okay are you guys superstitious or no
you guys it doesn't give any like pre
pre performing rituals
No
you guys just have to like I used to
before you go on always I always like a
good like mouth smooch I used to get
crazy nervous but like I used to get
diarrhea before we perform like really I
was I just get so nervous to perform but
diarrhea makes you funnier on stage that
you know the desperation yeah the rock
gets diarrhea before you do every time
you watch The Rock in a movie he is
holding back that area and it makes him
funnier or rest yeah
yeah I mean look he's one of the biggest
movie stars in the world yeah I know
exactly
so yeah LeBron James also have diarrhea
gives himself he eats a lot of soft
fruit it's weird he doesn't naturally he
has great bowels
he has very odd one bowels oh yeah he
will I mean before last night's game he
just loaded up on John Capel means like
if I need to get off the court so I got
it start to Cory I got to get to this I
got I got to do this yeah that's how you
got that block yeah I just had a class
awaits is like that's what you couldn't
hear oh my god exploded switched it
Mario Kart yeah this killer is let's
switch we're gonna switch guys we can't
keep this is just it's demoralize so we
just posted the Will Arnett sex tape
yeah a little bit we shot this bit where
will arnett what was it he want to eat
these like they're fun but they're
discuss how they get you wrong but I get
you I'm going in for whatever this is
grass grass clippings is a welcome
relief Oh puke what is that one oh the
worst one might be spilled milk ooh I
don't want that oh well that's really
bad but puke is God what is puke look
like all right I'm gonna that's it's
actually kind of it looks I'm thinking
wrong clapping above I'm also drinking
straight vodka are we allowed to
favorite video game consoles my parents
always got me the wrong ones so I had
like um 3do which was you know anything
about anything that was I also had the
Sega CD I had the atari lynx instead of
the gameboy I had a calico instead of an
ATAR
you watch movies on beta I know though
the only time they ever got like right
was when my parents got me a Genesis but
still the Genesis was verses like no one
had a Genesis I yeah like altered beast
right no one else is playing ultra
altered beast and Joe Montana football
now I am all Xbox Xbox one although I'd
like to get a PlayStation to play
Uncharted oh yeah our chart it's really
fun we had two guys I'll go out vs. race
there there we go alright everybody hit
a there are awesome consoles but no one
had him I had pigs and space on
colecovision okay item yeah you could
pick whoever you want okay you're down
there
all right right if you don't want to if
you want to be one of the characters you
can hit B I think and it'll go back
won't want to be water here you go yeah
you know you can choose your guy
unbelievably this dragon thing tari Lynx
was great because they had California
games wait today today sorry that's
right okay let's we thought you were
here let's switch you bet you want to
drive on this crazy thing all-time
favorite game series I'm going peach man
well people say Xbox one is not a good
game systems that wow look at that
that's some big oh there we go
I don't know what any of this stuff is
so I just all right yeah you could
choose your little car or whatever Omega
like that see I chose the you know the
hot girl sitting it's gonna distract you
guys I like it I don't know so you
definitely are picking strong female
character that like yeah always always
uh-oh no teams should we go let's try a
hundred cc then we'll work out 200 I
love it we're cup to a waterpark
why don't we are you know it's hot today
it's hot yeah exactly it's a hundred and
eight degrees it's a hundred and eight
it's crazy what do we do with our lives
by the way don't know if you guys are on
snapchat but a little time if you do a
snap and you put the temperature and
it's over a hundred and you send it to a
friend you get a trophy you get over 100
today
woo now my breath smells like spoiled
milk but not from the Jelly Belly's from
what I was eating earlier also somebody
stole my I did love my colecovision
because they had virgin clinco vision
the Smurfs
and you just basically just jump open
and get a Gargamel's house there yeah
all right so I think all right so the
right trigger it's like slide okay hey I
believe is go uh-huh
I think that's all you need oh yeah oh
and I how do you and I left trigger I
think is how you use your little items I
am a big Wario felt all right that
trigger why do I think what yep oh why
am I going to the water in the water
what's the turbo on here
when you get the mushroom okay and if I
want to throw something um I think that
left trigger all right and if you hold
like if you have a shell and you hold
the left trigger it'll kind of drag it
behind me
[Music]
am i under water I think so I think
never under water I feel this is so
refreshing it really is I don't have
air-conditioning my apartment so what
are you cereal or no no no that's a
terrible thing I'm work on TV naked all
the time you better stay here naked wait
how did that work Helen what did you I'm
gonna I'd have in there it just doesn't
work that way I got it and my landlord
is you know you know the worst but
here's the thing I got a great location
okay
it's one of those things we're like I
hate my apartment but I like where my
apartment is weird I know I live over in
Los Feliz oh yeah like read by kind of
over like mess hall and and yeah so it's
like I got a great view at Downtown the
only problem is I have to then live live
above the boulevard below the bar I live
in the poor side yeah I mean the cool
side side yeah that's it keeping it real
yeah yeah you don't only live above that
Boulevard yeah yeah no it's get caught
in that Greek Theatre trash oh god the
worst guys were talking very
specifically right now I went to I know
Ritsuko I went to up a party at somebody
like a friend of a friend's house who
lives on the rich side of the boulevard
yeah they had a a buffer fireplace a
real Buffalo head oh my god and I was
like what it was like dr. feelgood's
house no real doctor good video are we
allowed to kill buffaloes I don't know I
mean I hope they got it in like a
vintage sale I went that wasn't enough
it was a dumbass in Yosemite that just
killed a buffalo because they put it
like a baby Buffalo in the back of their
car
what yeah they saw this buffalo in the
ice in the wintertime they saw a baby
Buffalo and they thought he was too cold
so they put him in their car oh boy and
then the rest of the family like
wouldn't the the Buffalo his family
wouldn't talk to him anymore cuz he'd
been in a car and like put the Buffalo
down or some
oh my I got tons of inspiring stories
yeah Wow some very sad news everybody I
just heard from the chat that Wario has
checked himself into rehab yeah we know
so we're playing him here but let's just
wish him good thoughts
yeah good luck Wario Mario where you
must have a lot of leg like insecurity
issues cuz Mario oh you know it's like a
star oh wow you're like Wario you know
it is oh I came in last
oh no we're done I can remember that
Buffalo dead this is fury leaf
I think I'm baby peach although I don't
know I think if I think like that you
better try Belly jelly bean yeah Beth
get in here get bathroom playing the
game where you just now choose a random
one you have to guess what play magic
pizza it says I'm on the cool side where
magic pizzas off to go to your house
right now you could have just said pizza
because all pizza is magic so I think
her name is a little redundant I did go
to a house that had a giant piece of
taxidermy are you going in the del
clothes marathon I am NOT going to
bilko's marathon I wish I were but I'm
not
yeah my life is super pregnant and I am
I have to make super pregnant super
pregnant does that mean very pregnant at
me like awesomely she's like a superhero
is pregnant she shoots babies out of bad
guys shoot some out of her vagina yeah
it's a pretty intense pretty eight it's
definitely not Marvel friendly more than
the Deadpool 5 plus it takes it takes
nine months to load her up oh yeah I
only shoot one who every shot yes you
really got one job I missed another nine
months and this is looting up this is
this is the this is your your items okay
got my this is like - like drift got it
like go I think B is like breaks but who
uses probably I know you never got a the
whole time yeah that's you know that's
that's that's it guys we are back
Ronald shear and Rob Huebel Rainbow Road
- tanzy love the rainbow alright it's
also gender equality Road ah the
kool-aid family foods dreadfully boring
come on you went after you watch that
favorite family moment is the September
pregnancy answer what's that I don't
know everyone's just telling their
favorite thing 64 people joined during
that clip so you're confused but we were
just trying to prove the family feud is
actually better than you think it's
Steve Harvey Chevy America character oh
hey guys mom's faster hats besides each
other he's the best improviser you guys
have worked with oh man that how about
it said it best your favorite then why
and then why you know I promise all
about giving it's all about yes and
sending us partner I love I love
improvising well Riggle plays with us a
lot Jack McBrayer plays with us a lot I
used to love back in New York
Conan had a writer Brian stack back who
is like the best and his wife Miriam is
like the best yeah she's great and if
you guys actually remember I don't know
this old late night thing I actually
still do it where somebody worked like
the director will accidentally cut -
someone in the audience yes I quote
unquote like screwed Conan that actually
started because our director at the time
Liz plaka cut to Miriam who is playing a
character in the audience at late night
that Miriam started like making faces
and that became like an actual bit that
we still do to this day because of
that's so has an area in there I don't
yet Brian Jack now works on Colbert oh
great
yes just fantastic yeah Brian McLean are
you guys you guys promised to wreck his
career because he that's a Rio's a real
bummer and you guys are real jerks about
that cuz it worked every year blood in
blood out it's like a gang you know I
would also say John glaze I would say
John glaze are super funny I'll say that
the few times I've played with Adam
McKay is really fun yeah he's a mean an
Oscar award-winning Adam McKay yeah yeah
because I only like to kiss up to people
who have uh Jennifer Lawrence is a great
improviser a really love my gosh Meryl
Streep I think with Meryl is amazing GDL
man man although he just always does
Lincoln which is kind of annoying but
you know it's so good such like Lincoln
at the grocery store
yeah getting ice cream yeah like II get
classic Lincoln king of history well
what am i doing alright I have a giant
plant growing out of my car I drove off
the cliff and someone fished me back in
actually in college one of my friends
didn't clean his car forever and had a
little sprout in the backseat really
right a lot of dirt in there when I was
in college we had mushrooms growing in
our shower perfect on purpose or no no
no I just by accident magic mushrooms no
mushrooms
I believe I met little frog caught me
two guys that was I was first last time
now back at the bottom I will say the
thing like la like having lived in New
York Nell a New York I Love New York of
the city but you you can convince
yourself to live in horrible in despair
about yeah just her rig dicus there was
this place I lived in we called the
snake pit and it was long in there like
a snake and me and three other dudes
never cleaned it up so it was a pit yeah
and it was like there were only two
windows now there's four dudes miss
rabbit two windows one on either side
and it just it was like a tube of man to
the world it was the worst and you know
and that's why I don't believe in
pheromones because no girl has ever
wanted to make out with us in that
apartment and it was just full yeah yeah
I had for a long yeah just like for a
long time I kept getting apartments that
had like sleeping lofts you know so like
I was sure I would sleep some loft and
the ceiling was like right here and like
note you know you could never get anyone
to come back yeah yeah get murdered I'm
not going in your love yeah I like to
sleep in my can this coffin with me and
there's like I would be this guy because
I feel like he's intimidating cuz you
can't see my feet wouldn't be this much
yeah expressions wait a second I'm also
gonna be pink shy guy
I like that pink should I guy overload
of man pheromones it's true it was like
always wet in there too weirdly like I
was humid moist oh it's very moist the
thing she was like if you've never lived
in New York do you guys ever have the
apartments with just the hot pole oh
yeah yeah it was basically a hot water
tube that had to go through your
apartment it's like a lightsaber and you
just like warm up around
I remember my this girl I dated at the
time her hot pole was right next to the
toilet so you would just every year I'm
terribly I always sound like a burn on
my arm from the hot pole oh it's the
worst um but now in LA you know you
don't have to have a hot pole because we
live inside the hot pole it's 108
outside 108 tick tock clock yeah it's
good to take a lot of it I'll just talk
about hot poles is make me want you guys
we only have a few more minutes with
Paul Scheer and Rob Huebel so if you
have any questions about crash tests
about a million things they've worked on
transparent Keanu Children's Hospital
the league while we hated gauntlet why
you hated gauntlet I mean I hate it
gully because we kept dying or if you
have questions about other you have
questions about celebrities that we hate
if you wouldn't have that gosh guys the
hot gossip can tell you under Vegas
already oh my god you guys bet you know
it's so hot in Vegas he's gonna
definitely go see Criss Angel that makes
Criss Angel so good yeah dad's air
conditioning favorite game favorite
video games my favorite game I've been
playing a lot of battlefront but I know
it's not a great game I just wanted to
understand horse yeah I just want it to
be better I'm a big Call of Duty guy
obviously I want to get into VR stuff I
feel like VR and the jam VR is gonna be
the it's the future oh I love what's
interesting to me about when I played
Star Wars Battlefront a I didn't realize
the old battlefront was better right oh
yeah wither but it's interesting because
I didn't realize how much of those Star
Wars sounds are in like yeah that's what
you want like it's got all this eat it's
like a girl that you shouldn't be dating
or something but it's like but it's yeah
there's enough good things up there yeah
yeah exactly yeah she's like a great
dancer yeah but yeah it's true because
it's like they like just the TIE fighter
sounded so I was like so holy now they
have
that's been Lando is gonna be investment
great that's great
before that I'm a big Arkham Asylum guy
- I love Batman's great super fun those
games are great I like Duty is easy I
mean not easy but like that's an easy
one I did a commercial for Call of Duty
oh there we go I did a commercial it's
on YouTube it was like a two-minute
commercial and I had to do my own stunts
and I almost got killed
oh my god what happened I had to go I
had to take a zip line holy jesus yeah
that's a real that's crazy
I didn't take a zip line through this
giant ball of fire and God and we did it
one time they're like it looks great can
you do it again and so I did it again
and then they've made this explosion
like too big and it burnt off all the
hair on the back of my head whoa it was
crazy
oh my god that's insane but uh but it
was a fun commercial that's pretty fun I
think my favorite video game right now
though is now you can see me the video
game when it's time to move yeah I mean
it's like a classic you know you get to
play all your favorite characters now
you can see me franchise
I think it's called now you can see me
yeah how would you say it now you can
see now you see me eyelid value I was
just like if Daniel Radcliffe is trying
to get away from the whole magic thing
why is he in the new how you can why you
can see me now you see the migraine you
see me good Swiss Army Man
yeah yeah that's supposed to be good
that's crazy oh by the way I gotta say I
saw well you were in the short film -
yeah short film a VR short fun no no no
short film you and with the woman's name
in the gala Michaela where you go to the
their own old Marty the cuddle party
that's good yeah are you the limo driver
in there no I am NOT looks like your own
looks like oh really
it really does yeah I was like this is
that's hilarious I only work with people
that look like she's a guy aren't I
double yeah you know and that person
works a lot in Hollywood
it was it's such a weird it's like a
single of like the limo driver and he's
giving like this look and I was like oh
like that's got to be like a knowing
look like it's sheer or something but
it's not
you know it just looks like sure crazy I
hope you're getting royalties there I'm
getting eyebrow probabilities for that
oh yeah how did that come about
how's the short film write it or do you
know I didn't write it I just a guy that
a guy that knows Jill Soloway from
transparent hey I won this guy that
knows Jill Soloway wrote it and asked me
and Michaela if we wanted to do it
sometimes people just ask you and you
have like some time that week and you're
like okay I'll go do this it's awesome
yeah yeah once it once I guess you're in
the community and it's big enough I am
just sucking at this fox hunt now you
can see me three let's dream light it
okay guys first of all it's called now
you see me can you now see me then you
will usually are we gonna see each other
what am i hiding for I think that I
think Woody Harrelson's character music
it was the second one a flop it didn't
do no he said I didn't even come out yet
I came out and like no one saw it no I
just like just like last weekend right
they said he meant like two weekends ago
and I literally like no one saw us so
now it's you can't you didn't see you
don't you see yeah no yeah nobody saw me
that's what it is do you like Arby's
people say there's not enough Arby's to
really make a strong distinction
do we have one Arby's that I know we
have Arby's out here they we do there's
a great one that has a giant sign of a
huge cowboy yeah that's the magic one I
like their warm roast beef I know you
guys are gonna be gross about this cuz
it's the Internet but I enjoy a nice
thick roast beef sandwich I do I'm not
even say that again but like super sexy
and slowly hello I can't do sexy I can
do I couldn't enjoy nice warm my mom can
drive if you're well you got a bike this
is the best oh yeah here we go
this is Altos whets yeah my friends have
this thing called meat week where we eat
once a year for entire week we barbecue
every night really it's great you go to
be week calm it's awesome what do you go
to it wait where's uh it's everywhere
how is your [ __ ] for that week it's
the worst but and then the next week no
joke is like kale week you got
to eat healthy you gotta balance you
have to this track is not very well
maintained because there is mud
everywhere like a rugged Cypress
blue-plate look me in the eye and say
that Rob revenge someone asked why no
more Children's Hospital because Rob
Corddry killed it killed it Rob Corddry
worst person on the planet worst person
on the planet decided that the best show
on TV wasn't good enough no I think it
just got you know we've done like seven
years of it so I think Corddry wanted to
just do other stuff you know it's good
to get out before it gets too stale you
know I agree
we just want be pretty television so
good we did three seasons of NTSF and it
was like and I'm I mean as much of you
what you want to leave people like not
hating it yeah that's true we did
success of the league and I feel like
you know we could have done five yeah I
think people would still watch the Liga
if people really do like Glee good I
mean it but I always feel like it would
you ever do like a league movie I don't
think there would be an audience for the
entourage movie yeah Jesus
there was an audience for now you see me
- yeah all right yeah only there was
yeah maybe not see I'm eating my gas I
might say I'm not getting any yeah
that's all go more human giant people
are saying let's do it they're you know
we've worked together a bunch you know
Aziz Rob and I like we always they're
kind of doing stuff yeah not as some in
giant but as people what is it Jim it's
what does it do when you throw your do
you guys have things to throw like I'm
throwing like turtles at people yeah
like Rob plays diseases dad you knock
out people on master of none and you
were great in it
yeah oh thank you a lot of people think
that's Aziz's actual dabba that was
actually mean it is weird the NCI you
guys have similar similar facial
structure yeah I think it's bogan
did you guys slide on that banana peel
like I did I did yeah that was the worst
no one talked us
oh so they would have a sausage fest
with us okay not sure which is happening
you just got oil
thank you only Inbetweeners mate see
films there you go
what do you guys hear some questions
like you guys make a lot of television
and movies what are some things that
inspire you you like what cheers amazing
back mirror awesome BBC show yeah Steve
Harvey in general my manbo good I've
been watching the Americans right now
I'm loved oh great mr. robot music I
just watched another one called Happy
Valley on Netflix did you guys know
about it it was good
that's crazy cuz now there's so many
show at this is true the golden age of
television I want to watch a show Bancha
here that shows really good that's often
right I guess and that's the perfect
time to catch up I only watch shows that
have ended so I know I can have a
definitive end point there you go
I know you know what that is actually
that is a great call because it's that's
what chefs start getting terrible yeah
24 it's n it's 12 so yeah preacher is
really good I think everything should be
like three seasons you know yeah and
then yeah and then maybe like a UH like
a made-for-tv movie yeah or everything
should just be miniseries yeah just
who's in a Happy Valley no one you know
it's another dish it's a British show so
they're trying to like solve a murder
but it's really good I feel like if you
guys can make kind of any Hallmark
made-for-tv Lifetime movie and feel like
you guys have a couple of those in you
oh my gosh did you see that yeah James
Franklin just made and mother may I
sleep with danger but it's all vampires
like wow yeah it just came out is it
serious or tongue-in-cheek I mean it's
all vampires so serious yeah it's a lady
my lady dynamite is amazing words turn
every day so funny man yeah watch Maria
Bamford show it's hilarious it's so
funny was it definitely rotten fish
Kimmy Schmidt show - oh yeah that's
great what do we think of the latest
Star Wars movie thumbs up for me I'm all
on board oh of course
yeah I loved it if I was great I didn't
see it I was busy celebrating Christmas
Captain America - Huebel or two or three
yeah you see the last to know were they
good they're great they are similar
there is good therefore is great oh
really Civil War I think it was like one
of my favorite Marvel cuz it first got
in America
my god Mary I'm a I wrote a couple comic
book oh really
yeah I wrote some Deadpool from Marvel
oh yeah yeah I get my own comic book for
boobs oh my god well yeah I don't come
up book about called aliens versus
Parker and it's kind of like Shaun of
the Dead meets aliens whoa that's
awesome and then because of that we got
to write some Deadpool's holy crap and
then yeah I definitely want to write a
comic book someday maybe I'm super fun
and hard oh really
yeah what makes it hard you're kind of
like writing directing and acting
simultaneous phone and all the beating
off - yeah like it does what to do with
one hand yeah hard the professionals
like you know probably Uncle Ben just
have beat professional beat offers yeah
well they're courting I mean they don't
do it to him they just do it yeah you
yeah and they just I hit the wall Oh was
bad
[Music]
Civil War dope oh there you go Paul
shears comic book link to Paul she
allowed get that sweet catch eesh yeah
yeah there you go
Rob if you could write a comic what
would it be like what what interests you
about superpowers if you could have a
superpower besides the whole super
pregnancy thing yeah yeah probably
um like creature where you could get
guys to do what you wanted or maybe yeah
just like lying around again shooting
the babies out I mean they never said we
can't I think that would be great like I
think that would be great just shoot a
bunch of babies out a bunch of super
pregnant like bikini models okay it was
like bikini models that are super
pregnant and they fart out babies oh
they fart out baby yeah well that's
where babies come from right oh yeah no
they're not sport amount yeah again my
wife isn't pregnant so I don't know how
it works I'm still freaking out yeah a
lot of that yeah I will say I think
terms of super I really like I think
being able to turn into fog would be
cool well at the fog you know like it'd
be so traumatic cuz you could win any
argument out no you shut up maybe like
poof but you could also come a ninja and
then you'll have more powers what's that
again you become a ninja yeah so you get
also just have the power of ninja and
then fog is a part of that yeah I saw me
it'll also be fun to possessing animals
cuz I feel I could just be really fun to
like I don't be a dog and just yes
crotch like all the time I love that the
superpower of people most people would
want well okay
cry might haven't said too much about
crime
you guys talking about sniffing crunch
yeah yeah man you want to get in on this
significant I crashed everything that
sounds pretty great yeah it's this great
club I have I'm just crushing it it's uh
it's a Facebook group so hard to play
this game and talk I know I think my
favorite part of piranha 3d someone
asked Oh what was essentially was doing
a scene that's not even in the movie
where my nose got ripped off by a
piranha and I was Mountain than those
letting a piranha bite your dick off
that was Jerry O'Connell my Dickens was
intact as you could see in the sequel
yeah that's right yeah how is ving
rhames Ving Rhames is the best man he
taught me a lot about butt implants
gotta know how to spot a but employers
yeah who's that butt implant
oh we've got a blood him is it secret
knowledge or can you pass along how can
how Rob and I could swell I actually I
actually think that he who got butt
implants a real thing yeah simples and
butt implants confused tip like there's
like you know those dimples above the
ear and yeah I think he may have thought
like they were all just the facts yeah
like he may have thought they were all
definitely but in fact he thought that
people are getting butt implants above
the bun
yeah oh no oh that's awkward yeah so but
I listened to him and I took it all
where it's like one of those things but
that's and you couldn't correct him it
at that no I would never want to Craig
that's yeah you never want gurgling
range the worst is luck yeah no never
the worst is like when you're introduced
to somebody and like a couple times but
you never remember their name are the
worst and then it's gone too far past
the point where you can ask oh yeah you
can't that's why I want your phone to
have a feature under that when you get
close to somebody everyone oh dude
that's that's a great app don't tell
people own your phone is skating for
people in your context yeah yeah
menu of their name that's a traitor oh
yeah that's so smart alright guys this
is the last race this so this is I think
I've won every game and I'm sorry but I
like to win never dead wiener DAPs all
around what does that even mean what's a
wiener dad I think we have to pull our
dicks out like a wet-nap
I want to see a penis implant they just
did the first successful penis implant
the shady fridge oh there's hope for you
and your tiny penis and it's weird that
they managed to do like a face like a
face reconstruct you're like where
somebody's no no that's a movie that's
face up Oh got it
I was thinking that was a documentary
Nicholas let's have them all pick who we
should be okay that's a good idea I
might take a while and the last two but
just the first ones we see alright today
yes I saw the witch Connor Holt the
witch was a great movie David Wain a
jerk in real life no David wins the best
dude that's great what do I gotta do so
pick your guy
all right back out on face off but with
dicks wait that's a good idea said Vega
Oh dick off I think I want to face off
with dicks Metal Mario Metal Mario I'm
gonna be uh how's the sex addiction
going that was from the league it's not
going well I'm still addicted to sex
perfect better worse things I love Parks
and Recreation I like parks and
recreation someone with the which sucked
[ __ ] you buddy the riches are great I
think I like Parks and Rec and more than
I like the office but that's nothing
against the office I think it was just
two great shows
yeah two great shows on both
yeah I like both of them talk about
assassin movie okay assassin Oh mainly
that he killed that guy I couldn't
believe it
yeah that's crazy they got it even
though you John wick John amazing excuse
coming out I think again is yeah they've
shot it I hate a okay tell you a dick
chicken is that just wear your tutu
dicks are coming together slowly and
then and then are they gonna touch are
they gonna veer dick chicken is
something from the league okay where did
you get your dicks and you get as close
as you can never flinches first perfect
um is the loser of dick check now why is
that terrible what would happen if two
people touch dicks like why just keep it
going
I think well we the worse would be like
I mean if you were if you were a
homophobic and you didn't want that's
true it would be buttoned dick chicken
because that would really be yeah like
that would be the you know I don't think
there's any dick chicken just sounds
like ass at a normal Saturday for what's
the most anticipated movie that we all
have in our minds I think I'm excited
about rogue one Suicide Squad
I think that pizza oh really I think it
all those Warner Brothers movies don't
are never pay off we're on the Warner
Brothers lot bro yeah page comes down no
but I am look they have to win me back
because [ __ ] terrible I think I want
to eat like a like a fried chicken jelly
bean what's right I don't know what that
is there's not a fried chicken what
maybe he's just a bad one Rob's gonna
Rob it really is Fried Chicken all right
is the last race tomorrow
here we go baby Park each dragon there
we go first movie I saw no theater was I
think the Star Wars Oh first movie you
ever saw the first thing they ever
Sunday
Peter why I don't know first concert I
ever went you Color Me badd opening up
for Paula Abdul really I I was there for
calling me back
Wow it was amazing oh yeah first concert
first concert from me was Billy Joel
started Christmas
for me was the BG's with my mom Oh
awesome yeah
who liked the Bee Gees more you were
your mom my mom and we made out dude
perfect
got lucky yeah that's the best night
what does your mother while we're paying
attention to the screen where are some
other questions that we can like I'll
prove it anyone I touch dicks it's a
chat how are you gonna touch dick
yes transformers cows in movie bb-8 turn
up the q robot as advertised I just I
just heard that Bill Hader and Ben
Schwartz were the voice of you well I
think that they'd brought in to play
around with the voice but I mean that
wasn't like they're they're not you're
not gonna have a voice is like pee poo
poo poo oh holy that's a great
impression is good I have a here spoiler
alert for you Star Wars fans here we go
b8 is Ray's father ah I got you
I just opened up in its Obi Wan's
hanging outside oh my god takes a
terrible turn
I gotta say yeah JJ knows what he's
doing well I'm looking forward to Star
Trek actually I'm a big Star Trek fan
and I like I'm looking for the judge
scientist Simon Pegg now in both yeah
both worlds Simon Pegg is like a an
alien he's naive of them real yeah yeah
do you not know the characters coming
back exactly when Rob you did a voice
for Despicable Me right I did how was
that it was super fun I I would say your
first one
I know I've done a lot of TV voices but
I think movie voice that might have been
my first one but the voice-over stuff is
the best cuz you literally show up you
know in a t-shirt and jeans and hungover
and use your voice and you get paid a
lot of money yeah so yeah I did have
voice for a cool show that no one
thought was gonna be cool cos the movies
though in the middle Tron I did it but
it looked like Animatrix and it was
really cool oh look at that gorilla
can't be stopped oh look at that biceps
biceps yeah I did axe cop with Nick
Offerman
and that was a fun one unbelievable
did you finish not 12 is that you them
yeah look guys you know what a lot of
you're carrying that you're carrying the
weight on the top I didn't talk to this
guy's chest he doesn't well now I want
to kind of finish I want up guys me and
Paula really want to plug Donald Trump
2016 he's won a guy in there vote vote I
vote early but Ops is really gonna help
the country out we're all gonna build
walls around our houses great and so I
vote for Trump also Paul Scheer Rob he
let's give it up for them Instagram both
for this guy transparent comes back in
the fall on Amazon Keanu's out now this
guy filthy preppy teens you can see out
fullscreen calm yes and pop starts out
now pop stars out now which is like oh
let's I'll believe that's a fun movie
throw your fights
I hear it's hilarious so follow those
guys thank you for joining us this is
bad see you guys next Monday Wow
you